what is going on with the economy as
prices seem to be going up everywhere
and you also just can't seem to order
anything things don't things aren't
things aren't there
yes we have disruption to the supply
chain not just domestically but globally
but the reason
that there is inflation creeping into
the system now is we have been pouring
money from a helicopter into the economy
since the beginning of the pandemic all
the stimulus programs all the relief
programs we now know at least a trillion
plus for infrastructure don't yet know
on the social bill but all of these are
very very liquid events in other words
pouring money into the system eventually
gets in the hands of consumers and they
start buying goods and services now
here's where it gets complicated the
goods and services they want are stuck
on a ship outside of the port of los
angeles from sometimes up to six weeks
that problem while the president has
tried to solve it has not been solved
yet companies that make things like cars
that used to rely on parts that were
inexpensive from the asian market can't
get them anymore and they try and source
them domestically at sometimes 30 40 50
percent higher prices that goes into the
product it raises the prices and there
you have inflation now if you believe
the supply chain is going to get
repaired those pressures should come off
my own opinion is that half of the
inflation is coming from supply chain
issues and the other half which is not
transitory which is more permanent is
coming from the fact that consumers are
flush with cash and want goods and
services like they did pre-pandemic
hey kevin good morning it's jonathan
here walk us through a little bit of
sort of the mix signaling the economy is
showing right now stock market mostly
good uh you know but obviously issues
with labor force the job reports have
been disappointing the last couple of
months you give us your just your
assessment right now we are now a year
and a half or so into this pandemic the
administration has certainly had
aggressive measures to try to to spark
growth and yet it's been sort of fits
fits and starts where do things stand
right now where do you think they're
going
well i think i'm very constructive i'm
very positive
you know i have investments in over 34
companies that are private in almost
every sector in america almost every
geography
the demand equation is insatiable it's
like it's was in the 60s and we have a
remarkable situation where the
underlying economy
is very very strong and so the fed is
saying to itself and they're a very
tricky situation their their mandate is
to watch for inflation and they're
starting to see it and they just don't
know how much of it is transitory you've
heard that word many times now over the
last few weeks so transitory would mean
no problem as soon as supply chain gets
better these these inflationary forces
go away we can stop raising rates but
they don't know that yet so they've
cleared that option and the market
assumes that's going to happen but but i
think the more interesting situation is
that we don't talk about much
our american economy now is so
productive because of new technologies
that were accelerated during the
pandemic just think of every company
nike being a behemoth has said in five
months they were able to achieve what
they thought would take six years
they're selling direct to consumers now
they have huge margins on those products
less reliance on retail and at the end
of the day this makes the company far
more effective and constructive with its
capital because it has all that data
what size what color what style the
whole american economy has gone through
this remarkable digital transformation
direct to consumer that's very very
efficient and our reliance on using
older ways of distribution that are far
less effective has been reduced that's
very pro economy very pro s p that's why
you're seeing the market be so buoyant
and optimistic margins are higher
productivity's higher the new digital
america 2.0 is here
kevin i have a question despite um what
you just said that these uh that the
market is much more efficient that
consumers buy directly from retailers
there's still an enormous shortage of
workers you see it everywhere you go and
that is one thing that's holding back
the economy and some of the number of
businesses do you see that uh easing in
the next year or two or is this
something we have to live with
you know it's a great question and and
there's two forces at play first of all
remember we paid many people not to work
and those programs are just coming off
now
september was when some of the checks
stopped so companies that were trying to
hire workers particularly in the
restaurant and service industries were
fighting against the government it was
kind of a strange program work for the
government do nothing or work for
business so hopefully that's going to
stop that's number one but number two
and you may find this statistic rather
remarkable most companies including mine
tried to determine last year last
december what they what number of
employees were not going to come back to
the office and we made the assumption
along with many other companies in the s
p that that would be about 15 of the
employees those that were in accounting
logistics and compliance they used to
sit in cubicles wouldn't come back well
now i have the data at least for my
companies and they're a broad swath of
companies probably 10 000 people
included in the supply chains for these
companies 55 percent are not coming back
to the office more than half not now not
ever and as a result of that they've
they've moved to places where they can
stay with their families take care of
elderly parents they've left the city
completely they're never coming back to
the office and a result they won't work
inside the cities anymore in their
little cubicles at the desk because
they've proven to the economy they can
do it remotely using the technology
we've we already talked about so this
has put a lot of pressure on the
traditional job markets the head of my
own accounting in my operating company
that oversees all of our investments
said to me i grew up on a farm i'm going
back to a farm i'm going to live on the
farm and i'm never coming into the
office if you don't like it i'm going to
work for somebody else think about that
that's exactly what's going on
everywhere well and i've i've spoken to
some uh groups of women uh lately
getting out again for know your value
and all of them raise their hand when i
say you know who's remote and do you
like it they love it they get so much
done and they can still do their jobs
and it frightens me because i feel like
women are just going to take on more
more in the house but uh but yeah no
this is a huge reality in a conversation
we need to talk about
commercial real estate um kevin um
you know is that something you should
say you should be short on at this point
well you know another great question i
actually sold half of our commercial
real estate portfolio uh not because of
the pandemic because it became too large
in terms of our diversification mandates
but then when the pandemic started we
continued to sell down commercial real
estate because what are called cap rates
in other words the value of the building
is going down
particularly aaa office in boston new
york and other major cities because you
know the law firms and the financial
services companies are cutting their
need of real estate so commercial real
estate's in a bit of a funk right now as
we try and figure out the the owners of
the buildings are very optimistic
everybody's coming back but that's not
the only problem many of these buildings
were built over 20 years ago where there
has match systems there the the air flow
systems the the way they work within a
pandemic environment is not good enough
for people to want to go back into the
building the air circulation isn't
filtered and all those things the
washrooms aren't configured for pandemic
or for flu and as a result
millions of dollars have to go back and
to change that and that puts a lot of
pressure on it i want to just say one
thing about women in our economy you
might find this interesting
over the last seven years
the majority of my returns in my private
companies have come from companies run
by women particularly during the
pandemic they were remarkable in
mitigating risk and that old adage if
you want something done give it to a
busy mother applies perfectly to small
business in america so now i'm very
biased i generally invest in women-led
companies because they return my money
back faster
yeah i can totally see how that happens
and agree with you completely by the way
elizabeth do you know what um kevin's
nickname is on shark tank i do not it's
mr wonderful
and now i know why
but kevin has a lifestyle platform
called shop mr wonderful tell us about
it i'm in the wine business i have a
very large wine business and we learned
that people didn't want to go out to buy
wine anymore in stores a case of wine
weighs 39 pounds and we discovered that
people's propensity to shop for wine in
42 states where we're allowed to ship
them from our vineyards to them directly
went up dramatically and and as a result
the demand for different varietals and
different kinds of wines went up and up
and up people started discovering wine
is a wonderful thing for people to enjoy
and so shop mr wonderful is a brand new
site that expands my wine offerings by a
hundred fold i'm curating wine for
people people trust me on wine i'm a
member of the chevrolet de testa van and
i choose it it's almost like a wine club
you can order a case you can order a
bottle you can order six months worth of
wine and it's doing very very well i'm
very proud of it i just love wine you
know it's one of those things that i
love to grow love to make my wife and i
do it together it's a wonderful family
business but boy has it ever grown and
shop wonderful is trying to accommodate
that growth if you like that video wait
do you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe